begin with breaking news a french court
has handed down a guilty verdict against
the only survivor the only surviving
suspect of the 2015 paris terror attacks
18 other men were also found guilty of
planning and aiding the assaults that
killed 130 people in the french capital
seven years ago militants you may
remember burst into the bataclan concert
hall killing fans and staff alike while
further attackers targeted other
locations at the same time across paris
the verdict comes after a nine month
trial the largest in modern french
history the reading is still underway
we want to go now to lisa luishi is at
this palace she's at this house that was
built actually for this trial lisa let's
start with what we know so far the main
suspect salah abdullah he has been found
guilty on terrorism and murder charges
what did we learn about
the man and his motives during this
trial
well exactly he has been found of
terror-related charges and the judge has
decided to condemn him to life in prison
and that life in prison time cannot be
reduced that is really an extraordinary
verdict here tonight in paris in this
mammoth after this mammoth trial on
the most atrocious terror attacks on
french soil after the world war ii here
in france and also the uh the the head
of the tribunal tonight he has found
that all the 20 accused six of them in
absentia they all have been found guilty
of having helped with these terror
attacks on french soul soylent only one
was found not to be guilty of
terror-related charges so it looks like
it really has been will be a very very
tough verdict on all the accused here in
this trial and we know elise that this
terror attack it continues to influence
french politics today particularly
domestic politics but what about
the the victims of this terror attack or
what does this trial what does this
verdict mean for them
these 10 months have been really
important for the plaintiffs here in in
this terror trial i've been talking
talking to several of them and they
really found each other doing these 10
months at court very intense hearings a
lot of them about 400 of them actually
testified in front of the court and told
everybody about their pain about their
loved ones that they lost about what a
horrible night they had to go through on
the 13th of november 2015 and this whole
you know this whole trial the different
stages of the trial have been really
important for them and for their healing
process and some of them also told me
that they were terrorized
thinking of today's verdict because
during these 10 months they have
listened to some of the accused and the
accused have told their stories and they
you know the people i've talked to some
of the civil plaintiffs they told me
these people also are actually human
beings and some of them might have been
caught up in this and it will be very
tough on them obviously also if they are
being handed down very tough verdicts
okay dw's lisa louis with the latest
from this
trial the verdict just coming down
for these convicted terrorists
thank you lisa
you